Starting an online store
is easier than you think.
Let me show you how to
quickly open one with Shopify.
First, go to Shopify.com
and start a free trial.
Next, create a beautiful
online store without any
design or coding skills.
Use one of Shopify's professional
templates and easily change
fonts, colors, and images.
Next, add products.
Just upload a photo and
give your product a name,
description, and set a price.
Activate Shopify payments and
enjoy zero transaction fees.
Now let's open your store.
Just remove the password and tada!
Your store is live and
ready to take orders.
Are you ready to join the
millions of businesses
already using Shopify?
Go to Shopify.com and open
your online store today.